this week on quadriga refugee tragedy
europe in the dock
last week shipwreck off the italian
island of lampedusa focused attention on
the thousands of people who risked their
lives every year trying to reach
europe's shores
people are fleeing hunger poverty and
civil war from countries across the
middle east asia and africa
now politicians and human rights groups
are debating whether to tighten europe's
borders or make it easier for refugees
to arrive safely
but is europe doing enough to improve
the situation in poor countries and to
get to the root of the problem
your host this week ali aslan
hello and welcome to quadriga
it was only a year ago that the european
union won the nobel peace prize it's a
very different story these days as the
institution is being heavily criticized
for violating the very same principles
that it won the award for so now the
question is how and if the lampedusa
tragedy will affect eu asylum policies
and we will look at this very intricate
and complex issue on today's show
together with three experts who've been
following this issue very closely
welcome to
christian jacob who's an editor and
reporter for the german daily newspaper
d tuts where he writes primarily about
migration issues
michel schterman is a renowned historian
and the chief correspondent for the
german newspaper divelde previously he
was the director of the german institute
for international and security affairs
and laura lucchini who is an italian
journalist writing for various new
newspapers such as the italian lin
kiesta and the argentinian newspaper la
nacion
welcome to you all michael sturma a
tragedy indeed which occurred off the
coast of lampedusa 300 people at least
300 people died mostly from eritrea and
somalia and this incident this tragedy
has kicked off and sparked a very
emotional debate about eu asylum
policies is this debate long overdue
it would always be with us because this
is a problem without any without a
solution there's no straightforward
solution what you said in the beginning
it's a tragedy and the the the essence
of a tragedy is that in the end
uh the stage is full of
blood and misery
um
if we do nothing
this movement is going to increase it's
a huge secular
i mean the dimension of a century
uh
exchanged between or exchange
the africa is sending its toiling masses
to
europe
often
in the hope of
being welcomed or at least being
tolerated and this is of course
possible to a limited extent where to
put the limit nobody has the faintest
idea the controversy is raging very high
and
by and at the same time when europe uh
on its own has a number of problems
mostly related to demography and we will
look at those problems and also why
these refugees are taking these
incredible risks to come to europe uh
this is not a rel this is not a new
phenomenon is it we're talking about it
now as if this is a relatively new
phenomenon which it isn't 25 000 people
have been killed in the past 20 years
trying to get to
europe from impoverished countries
why do you think
this tragedy which just occurred why do
you think
such big emphasis is now being focused
on the lampedusa tragedy as opposed to
the previous ones well it is true that
there has been immigration for 20 years
that is not being allowed to get in
there has been shipwrecking all the time
and there's been many drownings but this
one is the biggest and i think that's
the reason why europe cannot continue to
ignore what is happening in the
mediterranean anymore and
if if we look at the asylum claims
these are the biggest numbers of asylum
claims in europe since uh 2005. 300
000 people
have been
applying
do you think
what do you make of this uh is is
the problems have have the problems
grown or or is it just a different
phenomenon that we're talking about it
is true that at the moment we are facing
the biggest asylum claims in the last
decade but uh earlier earlier years
there have been much higher numbers and
europe
took the consequence to try to prevent
refugees from coming in
we can observe a changing in the
european migration policy from about
1990 1992
um trying to prevent people from
claiming their right to asylum europe
states that it is a space of protection
for people who are politically
persecuted all european member states
bound themselves to the geneva refugee
convention all are saying that they are
giving their offering asylum to those
who need it but at the same time no
european country has opened up illegal
access
for asylum seekers there is no way to
enter to europe and to to to try to take
advantage of the of the asylum right
that is
guaranteed by the european um
well constitution and by the european uh
international treaties that the european
countries have um
so fewer legal claims for the uh
for the refugees to to call upon the eu
for asylum let's look at italy laura
lukini a country you're from obviously
a country that is plays a very pivotal
role here in the european union when it
comes to migration issues 30 000
migrants have reached italy only this
year this year alone and italy is
complaining it says it is unfair that it
is supposed to share it is supposed to
bear the burden and pay the cost
and is asking its eu partners to share
that burden is asking for mon for more
money is that the solution more money
yeah of course it's also an economical
uh problem uh italy uh is asking for
more support from the european union and
that
means also more money uh they there's a
huge sense of frustration in italy
because the the country the people feel
that they they have been doing a lot to
accomplish with the targets of the
european union but when it comes to an
emergency european union is not helping
italy
of course you have to put it this in in
situations in a context italy is uh
find itself in a in a strong economic
crisis and find itself also in a
constant political crisis so the people
are are frustrated
and
i think the european union should should
point this issue uh
in a in a joint way just because it's
really difficult to deal with it
with all different laws in different
countries and in a joint way is what the
eu and tyrion ministers have tried in
luxembourg they have failed to formulate
a common eu asylum policy italy is not
the only country here of course that is
in the focus mikhail germany is also
another country that is very much uh
looked upon when it comes to the
migration issue um the president of the
eu parliament martin shaw says who
himself is a german says germany must do
more must take in more uh refugees the
interior minister hans peter friedrich
though says
not at all germany is already doing its
fair shares taking in s times as four
times as many refugees as italy does
germany need to do more here
well germany is the strongest economic
power
but germany is also very central and all
the it's at all the crossroads of river
but almost all the crossroads of europe
and there is of course a kind of moving
limit
to what germany can do and will do
without upsetting
the situation at home
it's all very well to
in a well air-conditioned room in
strasbourg to be very generous
and it's a very different thing if you
go to heisenbergel in munich or to other
places
where we had very very serious concerns
during the mid 1990s
when even the oktoberfest was under
threat of not being able to be held and
celebrated
and that really
well that was for uder the very popular
mayor of munich that was the tipping
point when he said enough is enough
this is not a party political thing it
sounds when
like a party political thing when
martin schultz says so but this is
this is basically the president of a
parliament which has no real not the
real character of not the strengths and
the responsibility of the parliament
it's all very nice it's like me writing
an editorial
and sounding good and helpful but the
real problems are of course push and
pull factors of the most serious kind
the
most of africa is in turmoil there's war
poverty climate change there are
of course criminal gangs
who take advantage of these poor people
uh mostly young men
who risk everything including their
lives and pay a lot this is big business
among other things so very well to
display your bleeding heart but you
mustn't forget that there are very very
real and very serious tragedies behind
all these movements and that there are
no ready-made solutions there are
partial solutions small solutions five
percent
ten percent solution and the problem
isn't so new ten years ago the spanish
coast guard exceeded in numbers of
vessels the spanish fleet
and that the reason is very obvious but
still the issue remains christian
let's let's stay with germany here for a
second you may disregard what
the president of the european parliament
martin schulz said
in calling upon germany to do more but
he's not the only one by any means
germany is the biggest country in the
european union with 80 million people
in your opinion christian jakob
is
germany failing in its uh obligations
here yes morally this failing for sure
germany is one of the most important and
biggest countries in the european union
and we can observe that in the last 10
15 years it has managed to push through
its interests towards especially the
southern european countries and the
countries at the external borders of the
european union it has established an
asylum system within the eu that is
extremely unfair and that is loading the
entire burden of the immigration influx
to the to the countries at the extended
borders we have it is it is true that
the numbers of asylum seekers that
arrive in germany are rising there will
be about 100 000 in this year but at the
same time
hardly any of them can stay here because
germany and the other central european
states have set up a regulation which
only allows asylum seekers to really
claim asylum in the country where they
entered the european union which is
generally one of the countries at the
mediterranean coast the so-called dublin
ii regulations and two now the dublin
regulations and
this is by no means according to the
economic power
of the central european states so what
do you make then of the remarks on the
part of the german interior minister
hans peter friedrich who says
well aren't we already taken in four
times as many people as italy is he
incorrect it is well it is correct that
there is a higher number of asylum
applications here in germany but this is
not it does not this does not mean that
there is a higher number of asylum
grants in germany
actually sweden is one of the countries
that is accepting most refugees within
the european union the united nations
commission on refugees always um
is always
referring to sweden saying that if all
countries of the european union
including germany would relative to
their population take as many refugees
in sweden the unhcr wouldn't have a
problem to distribute distribute the
people in highest need anymore but
sweden is also sending very very serious
signs of distress
and unrest
and there is you can study it especially
around stockholm and in the south of
sweden you can study what happens if the
balance between
indigenous population and refugee
population
is somewhat reaching a tipping point
from
and after that tipping point things get
out of control and get pretty dangerous
for the social fabric and let's talk
about the tipping point laura lucini
because as mikhail suggests that the
main reason perhaps why eu countries are
reluctant to take in more refugees are
for domestic reasons
uh in italy the same we've had the rise
of far-rightest parties who have played
upon this issue yeah i mean
the the the xenophobic party legend
played a role in particular one in 2002
when this the new immigration law in
italy was was approved the this this
load possibilities
takes is his name from the two leaders
who was the leader of this xenophobic
party and the apostasis the leader of
aliens nationally uh john franco finney
they they are no more in politics but
the and this this law is according to
human rights organization uh really
really bad
and
it is uh
it it gives
the order to the to the uh
the villages that receives uh immigrants
from the sea to denounce these those
immigrants and it allows to put them in
jail so we have another problem the
jails are full and now the president is
talking about an amnesia to a proven
amnesia so there are
uh political internal problems but in in
the last year the the xenophobic party
lost a lot of
support and the phosphorous party who
was in the government doesn't exist
anymore so i wouldn't say that it
pushing up these movements right now it
would wouldn't be fair and another
domestic issue which
has been pointed out here is the
economic crisis that is uh
you know going through europe uh 26
million unemployed people in you in the
eu mainly young people particularly in
spain but also your country um italy do
you understand the reluctance on the
part of some politicians to say look we
would like to take in more people but
our hands are tied to it because we
cannot we
you know we cannot even care for our our
own people
it
it keeps the perfect ground for a public
right-wing
party to
to be
bored
but
yesterday a new right-wing party was
announced in italy and i mean that
there's like there's a ground in which
some party could could suggest that
would were letting alone we have been
let alone from by europe on this issue
and
and uh
our we don't have work for our uh people
and we cannot accept
any other people so there's the actual
government and as as to pay attention
with this uh with this argument to be to
be raised i'm not so sure that it's just
a left wing a right-wing thing i
remember oscar lafontaine
uh making a lot of hay out of this and
talking about friend albeiter the famous
famous left-leaning german politician
party leader
the charisma wars and still is
indirectly through his wife
the number one guy
for the linker especially in the in west
germany the leftist party uh so
i think that was a sign that this is
that that's where the extremes meet but
do you think that's a legitimate
argument to say there are people 300
people dying off the coast of italy
people who risk everything to get here
and it's the argument to say yes but we
have a financial crisis that we need to
deal with is that a legitimate reason
for you it's so out of proportion
300 people dying off the coast of italy
or lampedusa is a terrible argument it's
a terrible thing to see it it it hurts
every human being's feeling i think
at the same time it is a symptom of a
crisis
or of
northern africa
which we cannot solve
with no amount of money no amount of
development aid no amount of uh
police
you cannot solve these problems you can
help to contain them
and that's really where we should do
much much more but isn't the reality
that people will still keep common
despite the risks well for a combination
of reasons of course this terrible
poverty the the fear of war
uh look at south sudan look at the
butchery that is happening look at mali
where where we just about sort of
avoided a major catastrophe uh not
thanks to the german government but
thanks to the french government
um
these problems have a magnitude of which
we see just the the the
harbingers
not much more and there is much more to
come and there is of course the side of
the of organized human trafficking
that's a very important part it's not
only that
you have there there's a
kind of disorganized misery you have a
very well organized misery with people
who make a lot of money out of this
and then they don't even deliver very
often
although the 300 coffins or the 300 dead
corpses
in lampedusa
i mean they really hoped for some
delivery the same hope that drove
millions and millions of europeans to
america
a century ago
no solution
no solution i mean real solution we can
always put some aspirin
into the proper that would throw some
aspirin to the problem and some millions
to the problem but that is not the
solution so christian yakov no solution
says mikhail
because simply there will always be
conflict places if you will in the world
where people are suffering whether in
north africa or or mainland africa
what do you make of this argument so so
where's the solution then at the end of
the day is there a solution or is there
none as mihoshtamas suggests well there
is of course going to be problems all
over africa in the future as well but
the point is not that everyone from
africa wants to come here it's not that
everyone wants to get to europe the
history of germany and the history of
europe shows that not necessarily in the
moment that migration policies being
more liberated and and more open
everyone comes in the first the first
time the freedom of movement was in the
european union has been introduced
everybody was fearing that the people
from the poor southern european
countries would come up and move in the
north when the extension of the european
union to the east towards east germany
has come everyone said people will flee
from the post-socialist countries in the
eastern
eastern region and they will come to
western europe because there are more
jobs there are higher wages and everyone
is going to leave its home and finally
2011 when the restrictions for the job
seekers from the
eastern european countries in
bulgaria and romania have been relieved
and they got the right to come in and
seek for jobs within the european eu's
labor market everybody was fearing that
they were going to come in they were
going to work for dumping wages they
were going to ruin the german or the
central european labor market and the
social systems and none of this has
happened but let's be very concrete here
the 300 people
who died off the coast of lampedusa
mainly came from eritrea and somalia two
countries that are in state failed
states
if you will human rights abuses rampant
human rights abuses
what do we do with these countries what
do we do with the situation as a
european nation as germany as italy as
spain as france how can we help well
there are basically two possibilities
one is to keep everything as it is to to
to europe
can lie continue lying to itself saying
that it is binded to human rights and to
the geneva refugee convention saying
that there is a possibility for people
in need for people who are persecuted to
get protection here and at the same time
continue to seal of its borders and
and
keep on watching how the people try to
come here to try to get protection here
die or it can start to take the geneva
convention and its obligations to the
human rights series and open the
corridor for people to get in what do
what do you make of the arguments that
some people put forth
uh let's try to fight the source of the
problem mainly let's try to improve the
living conditions uh of those peoples uh
in africa and northern africa well
i'm all for it but
it's basically
feeding aspirin where uh really colorize
the disease and then take a problem like
the syrian civil war syria is falling
apart nobody has the faintest idea of
what kind of syria if at all will there
be in five years time or in ten years
time meanwhile
one tenth of the syrian population has
fled the country and probably
another half of the population would
like to do so
what the minimum we must do apart from
all the reasonable things that have to
be done
the minimum we must do is differentiate
between
refugees who are driven out of their
normal habitat through
war and civil war
and who may
and we may help them very much with
temporary shelter
temporary but this is like that
happening
uh this is this is
it's of course very difficult to say
temporary how long under what conditions
allowed to work or not to work
um
of course i'm quite aware of that but it
would help to take away some of the
domestic pressure the german interior
minister is also working under enormous
domestic pressure
we don't want an extreme right wing and
an extreme left-wing party to sort of uh
make hay of of of this very real problem
so
the debate in germany reflects very much
the dilemma the tragic dilemmas
we we are facing faced with
laura looking here we have a clear
conflict here we have a clear conflict
between
um the
human rights laws that kristen yacob has
mentioned and perhaps the real politique
domestic policies
shackles of domestic policy policies
that each politicians perhaps is bound
to how to solve this
i think there are few things that can be
done in the short term and in the long
term of course you can talk about
better
try to improve the condition of life of
the people
going away but the illegal immigrants by
maybe
agreements with with the government
from where those people are escaping
but uh i'm not talking about the
refugees but the illegal immigrant of
course we have to distinguish i agree uh
between uh
refugee or asylum seekers and illegal
immigrants so for italy in this moment
the problem is all together because
they're coming all together and
they have to deal with the with the
issue on on on the spot on a small
island lampedus where there are like few
thousand people living
and um
i think on the on the issue of asylum
seekers we can do something by improving
the condition
uh or to receive asylum in in europe and
to create corridors to to defend this
corridor to do to help these people uh
uh in in the sea in the international
water and uh and on the illegal
immigration that
we can do more on the spot by by trying
to stop these people to to come maybe or
trying to uh reach agreements with the
government there are the two different
things that has to be done in the short
term but i think
what europe should do uh it's to deal
the frontier the southern frontier with
the in the mediterranean sea as it was
at the european frontier and
not not like different uh like different
countries frontier that would be the
first step to to to find a common
solution but you have of course the
problem of national citizenship we are
all in a way
in an almost virtual way citizens of
europe right
but essentially
when it comes to civil law to
the welfare
we
europe is in the europe of nations
and that's why this idea it sounds
wonderful but it's far ahead of reality
and there seems to be an inherent
unfairness here uh vis-a-vis
some countries in in the broader context
here if we look at the numbers de facto
only 10 eu nations have to deal if you
will with the coming of these asylum
seekers whereas the remaining 18
countries there are 18 eu countries that
do virtually nothing about it mainly
also due to the doubling regulation
which you mentioned christian jacob
namely that the asylum requests have to
be handled by the country that the
asylum seekers arrive and where they uh
um
you know ask for uh asylum so that
basically leaves countries like italy
greece and malta always at the forefront
there seems to be no concessions though
on the part of the northern eu countries
well there is congestion consciousness
of course but it is very comfortable the
way it is it is super comfortable and
that's the reason why this regulation
has been established by the central
european countries and
there are uh propositions to make a uh
to to build up set up a system to
distribute the entire influx of asylum
seekers equally over all european
countries relative to the size of the
population and to the um
to the economic power of the countries
but uh since 2004 the euro the eu has
tried to set up a new asylum system they
have been negotiating on this for five
years the negotiations have finished in
december of last year and since june the
new asylum system is in power and
nothing has has changed it is still the
same the entire
european asylum architecture leaves the
burdens on the countries at the external
borders which are the weakest and
poorest
and many
people are asking themselves not only in
europe abroad how could this tragedy
have been prevented and in the context
of these questions always the name
of the agency frontex emerges and let's
have a quick look at the role
and the purpose of this agency
frontex is an eu agency tasked with
watching europe's borders and preventing
people from entering without papers
it works with and coordinates the border
agencies of the eu member states
but its budget has been cut drastically
over recent years
some politicians say frontex needs more
money for more patrols they say it
doesn't just stop illegal immigration it
also saves the lives of refugees trying
to cross the mediterranean in tiny
vessels
but critics have accused it of
endangering lives by stopping boats
offshore and escorting them back to sea
breaking the law by denying people the
right to claim asylum
christian jacob
is frontex the the problem here or the
solution well front text is neither the
problem not the solution it is an
instrument it is an instrument of the
european migration policy that mainly
tries to prevent people from coming here
there is a huge contradiction between on
the one hand the geneva convention
saying people can come here if they are
persecuted and we will grant them
protection and at the same time since
2003 europe is making huge efforts to
seal off its borders frontex is one one
part of the system then the other one is
being debated today in the european
parliament in strasbourg there is going
to be a new european border survey and
system implemented from december on it
is called eurosur and it's its duty
equally as is the obligate the duty of
frontex is to stop people who try to
come here without the visa which
practically means any anybody who seeks
asylum here
the european union risks its own
credibility and standing worldwide
doesn't it let's look at what happened
in the aftermath of this tragedy the
victims are getting a state burial
whereas the remaining survivors of this
tragedy are being prosecuted for trying
to enter europe illegally
is that in any shape or form consistent
with
the ideals and values that the eu set
out it's a blatant case of double
standards of course but it's also an
admission of helplessness
the state funeral uh
is so
it's grotesque
it's grotesque first you force you
enforce the situation in which these
things are bound to happen sooner or
later
near lampedusa near the spanish coast
near the greek
islands
and then
you send in
the big guys from the eu
and they say the appropriate things so
does the italian prime minister and
they cannot admit that they are helpless
because there is this push and pull from
uh
africa from syria from the arab
arc of crisis
and everybody knows we cannot open the
borders to everybody who is in need let
alone who wants to come because this was
would upset any social and moral balance
inside our countries italy has always
prided itself of being a country without
racial prejudice and such things
was something very liberal and a message
to the world
but since
at least 10 years if not 20 years
italians have seen that their
beautiful cities are filling up with the
black refugees from africa selling all
kinds of wares everywhere the same thing
so there must be big organization behind
it and italians are lost to admit
that there is a problem with which the
italian state cannot cope now this has
reached because
not only of lampedusa but because mainly
because of lampedusa this has reached a
point where i think things just cannot
go on as there are but i do not pretend
i have a solution there are many small
solutions at on at the edges of the
problem but not at the center michel
michelle says he doesn't have the
solution do you perhaps have one laura
lukini well of course i mean the the
problem with the with the illegal
immigrants that stays in italy has to do
with this immigration law that we have
because
those immigrants are
being pressing press charge for illegal
immigration if they
don't have documents with them they can
stay in italy in any legal way there's
no way to to even if they find a job but
there's no way to to change their status
they will be illegal forever there's no
way that an employee with a good will
can could change the status of these
people that put a lot of pressure on
employees and that put a lot of power to
mafia or people exploiting this
situation so that that's why there are a
huge uh organi
there are a huge organization that
they're exploiting these these people
for to sell uh illegal uh illegal stuff
sometimes because those banks the the
fake specs that they're selling in on
the street of italian cities are illegal
as well and uh
using these people for example i don't
know in tomatoes uh
uh camps in in southern italy uh
under the constant threat of being
denounced to the police so that that's a
problem that we have with this law that
there has been the instrument at least
to change the status of these people but
of course this problem is not just an
italian problem quite on the country
it's a european problem let's touch upon
the issue which has come up a few times
here namely the issue of trafficking uh
the smugglers uh that are profiting if
you will from
from the the uh
the the the bad fortune uh of these
people coming uh to europe or trying to
come to europe there is an argument that
they're saying closing the borders will
give even more powers
to the traffickers it will not solve the
problem quite on the concrete will
exacerbate the problem would you agree
well the entire
trafficking business is just a reaction
on the frontex policy as long as the
border is totally sealed off there will
be traffickers if there would be no
traffickers people would die anyway
because they would try to organize the
boats on their own they wouldn't stop in
north africa they would try to get boats
to set over to the
italian shores to the spanish coast and
the situation would be the same so it's
not the human traffickers who are to
blame for what is happening for example
in lampedusa it is the fact that there
is simply no way to legally enter europe
hans peter friedrich once more the
german interior minister said something
in the context of this tragedy he says
as much as we regret the casualties of
course it needs to be stated and made
clear that most of these asylum seekers
generally speaking are economic migrants
not political refugees
would you
does does do the numbers and you know
this issue quite well do the numbers
back up his statement well it is true
that not everybody who who comes over to
italy in a boat is a political refugee
and there are labor
migrants there is a labor migration it
has been it has been there always and it
will be like this in the future as well
but we should stop to regard this as a
problem uh
migration
research and also
a
macroeconomists are claiming that europe
and germany needs immigration and it
does not only need immigration from
within the european union but also from
outside there are different numbers on
this but even a
commission that has been installed in
the late 1990s by the party of minister
friedrich cdu has has tried to to
somehow evaluate how high the necessity
of immigration for the european economy
is for the german economy is
and they said that at least one hundred
thousand people should move in every
year in order to satisfy the necessity
of the economy and to avoid that the
european society shrinks
how helpful is this distinction between
economic migrants and political refugees
uh at the end of the day they're all on
the boat they're all trying to come here
and they are all uh if you will taking
the risks to get here so what does it
matter at the end of the day why they're
coming now economic migrants
are not
necessary they
perhaps they have a chance
to adapt and make a useful contribution
in the countries of arrival
even where they are at first
in the first place are not very welcome
i do not believe that
a hundred thousand refugees from syria
or from eritrea
can really
be the answer to the problem
uh that we are facing in terms of
european demographies because it's more
or less the same everywhere
you have to
i mean
bringing in
refugees who in
take the people from syria probably 99
of them would love to stay in syria
which is a beautiful country very
civilized uh
great cultural benefits but
the situation being what it is syria is
falling apart hundreds of thousands of
people are fleeing tens of thousands are
dead
they have never wanted they never wanted
to settle down in europe
and their qualifications to make a
decent living
are
in many cases good in even more cases
probably very bad
this is not
this this spontaneous
uncontrollable migration is not the
answer to what we really need in the
medium and long term and let's look very
briefly the last round because we are
running unfortunately out of time what
is it that we need what what needs to be
done here in the light of this tragedy
give us a couple of concrete factors a
combination of factors that are working
on our side and then working on the
other side
that includes development aid but it
also includes policing it includes
explaining and enlightening people
people have overblown ideas of the
paradise the land of milk and honey that
awaits them on the northern shores of
the mediterranean
laura lukini what what what is your
proposal here i think we should
establish uh force aid forces in the
mediterranean
from the european side and they told so
should be organized information centers
or place where the people could the
zealand asylum seeker could go to to get
information and to to travel safer there
are two things that could be done in a
short term
christian
we've talked about the pros and cons
here on the show extensively last word
uh goes to you what does the eu need to
do now your the european union needs to
stop to regard migration as a threat it
needs to um allow refugees to get in
legally without risking their lives and
dying in the mediterranean sea while
trying to get to europe and the european
union needs to start to set up a system
that equally and fairly distributes the
burdens of asylum
amongst other member states and do you
think that will happen realistically
speaking i'm afraid it is not so likely
and
so so a rather pessimistic tone than if
i understand you correct we have seen in
the last 20 years that the policy has
always been towards the the
prevention of immigration and i'm afraid
that just because this time 300 have 300
people have been dying in one day
this is not going to change so easily
well the eu ministers eu interior
ministers in luxembourg could not come
to an agreement and the
eu asylum policies are still not unified
and common and i'm afraid we too on the
show could not find uh common ground but
i think we've highlighted very well the
issues that are at stake here and we
will of course hear equadriga continue
to follow the story very closely i want
to thank my guests
for their opinions their insights into
this very intricate and complex not
black and white issue i want to thank
you out there for tuning in and looking
forward to seeing you again next week
for a new edition of quadriga
you